- À 43 ans, le jeune
premier ministre éthiopien
Abiy Ahmed reçoit
le prix Nobel de la paix 2019.
"C'est un prix pour l'Éthiopie,
mais aussi pour tout
le continent africain",
dit-il à son interlocutrice
norvégienne.
Au pouvoir depuis un an et demi,
le plus jeune dirigeant africain
aura accompli beaucoup.
À peine au pouvoir, il libère
tous les journalistes et
les prisonniers politiques.
Il met également fin à la guerre
avec l'Érythrée et signe
un accord de paix avec
l'ancien ennemi juré du pays,
le président érythréen
Isaias Afwerki.
Il instaure également
la parité dans son gouvernement
où les ministères de la Défense
et de la Justice sont
détenus par des femmes.
À Addis-Abeba, la nouvelle
a ravi la population.
"Je suis très heureux,
dit-il. Toute la paix qu'on vit
en ce moment, c'est grâce à lui.
Vraiment, je suis heureux."
"Il a tant fait pour le pays,
dit-elle. Il a réconcilié
les patriarches orthodoxes,
rapproché les musulmans
et les chrétiens.
Il mérite vraiment ce prix.
Le comité Nobel a précisé que ce
prix est aussi un encouragement
pour continuer dans la bonne
voie. L'Éthiopie se prépare
à des élections générales
en mai 2020 malgré des tensions
ethniques dans le pays.
Également, la construction
du plus grand barrage
hydroélectrique d'Afrique
en Éthiopie inquiète toujours
l'Égypte. Ce prix Nobel rappelle
à tous l'importance de préserver